Доброго дня шановні колеги сьогодні У
рамках тижня професійної освіти в
Україні інститутом професійної освіти
Національної академії педагогічної Наук
України спільно з директоратом
професійної освіти Міністерства освіти і
науки України проводиться вебінар
психолого-педагогічні технології
адаптації здобувачів освіти до умов
воєнного Слави
слід наголосити що саме в системі
професійної освіти відведена дно з
відповідальних місць у процесі творення
і розбудови нашої ві
тчизни науково-педагогічна спільнота
володіє сучасними знаннями має потенціал
силу та здатність забезпечити соціальній
економічний розвиток держави сьогодні
небайдуже до проблем професійної освіти
науковці педагоги сміттями запрошується
до дискусії щодо адаптації здобувачів
освіти до умов воєнного стану
виникла необхідність проаналізувати
основні проблеми системи професійної
освіти у контексті використання
психолого-педагогічних технологій
зокрема забезпечення психологічної
соціального супроводу освіти осіб з
інвалідністю застосування
нейромоделювання з метою керування
психологічним станом особи а також
Обґрунтування необхідності застосування
stem-технології у професійній освіті як
інструменту відновлення України
впевнений що сьогодні будуть
представлені нові ідеї та рішення
втілення яких дасть змогу модернізувати
національну систему професійної освіти
та підвищити престижність української
педагогічної науки на світовому рівні
Бажаю всім нам Перемоги а також доброго
настрою реалізації ваших планів і
успіхів здоров'я вам і благополуччя
а першим до слова
запрошується Лапа Оксана Вікторівна
кандидат педагогічних наук старший
науковий співробітник лабораторії
технологій професійного навчання
інституту професійної освіти у натон
України з доповіддю психологічні і
соціальний супровід освіти осіб з
інвалідністю внаслідок війни так само
Вікторівна будь ласка слухаємо вас
Дякую
коли Анатолію відкриваю презентацію
це займе декілька секунд тому що люди
приєднуються
ми бачимо вашу презентацію будь ласка
слухаємо вас
Дякую Отже тема мого сьогоднішнього
виступу це психологічний і соціальний
супровід з інвалідністю внаслідок війни
звичайно що це Тема надзвичайно
актуальна так як державна статистика
показує що в Україні наразі на березень
23-го року
більше
2,7 мільйона цивільних осіб та Майже 500
тисяч учасників бойових дій мають
офіційний статус особи з інвалідністю
Звичайно що через війну ці числа будуть
лише зростати
і це буде таким достатньо потужним
викликом взагалі для всього суспільства
для всіх і суспільних інституцій і в
тому числі для професійної освіти
звичайно
завдання
будь-якої держави зробити так щоб особи
з інвалідністю були соціалізовані мали
ті ж самі права що і інші особи які не
мають цього статусу якщо ми подивимося
на довоєнні цифри то в 2021 році були
працевлаштовані лише 17 осіб з
інвалідністю 17% від тих що було
звичайно навіть і ще на той час
наголошувалася
величезна потреба у розвитку
інклюзивного ринку праці Наразі це
питання буде надзвичайно актуальним і
для того щоб ринок інклюзивний ринок
праці був розвинений професійна
професійно-технічна освіта повинна
зробити свій вагомий
у підготовку осіб з інвалідністю для
того щоб вони достойно могли забезпечити
своє життя
уряд розробив план заходів на
23-24 роки з реалізацією національної
стратегії щодо створення безбар'єрного
простору
в Україні звичайно і заклади профтек
освіти теж залучаються до цього плану
заходів
окрім того Якщо ми будемо розглядати
сприяння
працевлаштуванню осіб з інвалідністю То
наразі розглядається законопроект Про
внесення змін до деяких законів України
щодо забезпечення права осіб з
інвалідністю і там передбачено що
будь-який роботодавець який працевлаштує
у свій штат 50 і більше відсотків від
штату людей з інвалідністю може
розраховувати на підтримку пільги а
також на соціальний супровід від держави
наразі стоїть не тільки питання про осіб
які мають інвалідність фізичну а також
стоїть питання ментального здоров'я так
Шановні колеги будь ласка хтось керує
презентацією
Я дуже прошу
прийдеться перезавантажити на жаль
Шановні колеги я дуже прошу не
перемикати самостійно слайди
що поки завантажується та повторна
презентація Хочу наголосити Шановні
колеги
звичайно моя презентація буде дуже
насичена текстом але я це зробила з
певною метою щоб ви мали можливість
застосувати у своїй роботі
і ті всі
матеріали які є у презентації
підвантажується
Є так Є Дякую Отже щодо ментального
здоров'я
за об'єктивними дослідженнями
певної вибірки яка становила більше 50
тисяч через тендентів 90% українців
наразі мають хоча б
мінімальну з симптоматику тривожних
розладів
і біля
45% потребуватимуть взагалі
психологічної допомоги та
психосоціальної підтримки різного
ступеня інтенсивності будь ласка
спроектуйте це на наших здобувачів
освіти Ми будемо мати ті ж самі цифри
коли що ще доводить те що проблеми
ментального здоров'я є дуже актуальні
якщо подивитися на безрецептурні
заспокійливі засоби то українці
витрачають в місяць близько 300
мільйонів гривень на їх купівлю але
дослідження показало що суб'єктивна
оцінка власного психологічного здоров'я
українців є досить високою тобто вони
вважають що із психологічним здоров'ям у
них все
добре і біля половини майже вважають
свій ментальний стан задовільним але
розуміти це суб'єктивні оцінки
тож наразі ми будемо мати десь 3-5
мільйонів пацієнтів додатково Тобто це
будуть від
психічні розлад розлади середній тяжкі
до потреби вже такого більш серйозного
медичного супроводу не може хвилювати те
що 66% респондентів сказали що вони не
знають коли куди могли звернутися за
допомогою у разі необхідності отже
взагалі і педагоги не тільки
адміністрація не тільки психологи
соціальні педагоги закладів професійної
освіти а буквально всі працівники
повинні знати як скерувати
здобувачів освіти члени членів їх родин
для психологічної допомоги Реально Що Ми
наразі маємо професійні освіті ми
провели власне опитування учасників
курсу психологічний супровід
внутрішнього переміщених осіб і ви зараз
маєте
можливість продивитися графік тобто
щодо категорії здобувачів освіти та їх
родичів які будуть майбутніми суб'єктами
діяльності педагогів психологів
професійної освіти
Тобто це дуже багато категорій починаючи
з дітей які постраждали внаслідок
військових дій ви бачите це як правило
буде найбільше категорія далі будуть
діти з інвалідністю і дорослі і члени їх
сімей і так далі І з усіма цими
категоріями звичайно
педагоги професі території освіти
повинні співпрацювати звичайно в нашій
країні забезпечується соціальний
супровід осіб з інвалідністю який
обґрунтований рядом законів України і
інших скажемо офіційних документів окрім
того наразі реалізуються Спільний проект
Міністерства у справах ветеранів та
України і Червоного Хреста з підтримки
ветеранів війни
розширюється проект є робота та
запускається нові грантові програми для
ветеранів для започаткування або
розвитку власного бізнесу звичайно ці
люди і дорослі мають можливість
навчатися на короткострокових програмах
у наших закладах професійної освіти
також відкриваються програми
мікрогрантів на розвиток власного
бізнесу З певних галузей господарства
а також окрім соціального супроводу
розпочинається державний такий
можемо сказати потужний психологічний
супровід осіб з інвалідністю Так зараз
реалізовується пілотний навчальний
проект система підтримки та супроводу
ветеранів у громадах це Хмельницька
Рівненська і Львівська область наразі в
цьому проекті І от за даними взагалі
психологів усього доведеться українським
психологам соціальним педагогом взагалі
здобувачам освіти та взагалі всім
соціальним інституціям доведеться
працювати близько з 10 мільйонами осіб в
Україні це не обов'язково особи з
інвалідністю А це особи з інвалідністю і
тобто і дотичні до них люди це як члени
їх сімей так і можливо колеги по роботі
І так далі тому за ініціативою Олени
зеленської розпочалася дія всеу цієї
програми ментального здоров'я яка
називається те як
метою якої є створення системи сервісів
і послуг які можуть різними способами і
механізмами підтримати українців у
складній часи війни і післявоєнного
стану також посилання на цей сервіс Ви
можете бачити у моїй презентації
на цих слайдах я розмістила матеріали
тобто
по розділам презентована матеріали поза
по самодопомозі та підтримці інших осіб
починаючи із розділу де базові навички
турботи про себе та інших розглядається
також до
допомоги це як самодопомога техніки
різні так і допомога іншим
особам також
презентована на цьому сайті вебінари від
ізраїльських фахівців онлайн лекції
практичні заняття під час яких ви можете
дізнатися відповіді експертів на певні
питання ці матеріали сервісу можуть
використовувати як практичні педагоги і
практичні психологи і соціальні педагоги
і скажемо люди які не мають базової
психологічної освіти окрім того діє
проект дитячого фонду юнісеф поруч
мультижанровий спецпроект жити далі це
відеоролики Ну і громадська організація
безбар'єрність надає на своїй сторінці в
Facebook поради психологів у прямому
ефірі
а також є матеріали сервісу скажімо по
менеджменту це аудит потреб громадян
послуга з охорони психічного здоров'я
ресурсів існуючої системи надання послуг
ну окрім того там розміщено дослідження
психологічного стану українців
безпосередньо на які я посилалася
у травні цього року не відбулася
міжвідомча координаційна рада з питань
охорони психічного здоров'я за участю
семи міністерств де презентували
програми відновлення ментального
здоров'я Шановні колеги я вас щиро прошу
звернути увагу саме на ці проекти це
скажемо от ваша дорожня карта подальшої
діяльності Ну і як цей значимо наш
прем'єр-міністр що ми маємо подбати про
повернення кожної людини до повноцінного
функціонування і щоб кожна людина
багато людина із особливими потребами
так скажемо Та яка не має статусу такого
Такого була спроможна самостійно дбати
про себе і про сім'ю тому я думаю наша
держава буде акцентувати на
створенні мережі сервісів та послуг для
того щоб реалізувати програму
ментального здоров'я і наша безпосередня
участь у цих програмах буде обов'язково
Отже які було презентовані проекти Ну
звичайно найперше це проект Міністерства
охорони здоров'я це охорона психічного
здоров'я у структурі медичної допомоги
на скільки я знаю що наразі на первинна
Ланка
[музика]
сімейних лікарів
також медсестер навчена скажемо надавати
першу психічну допомогу і в разі
необхідності лікар первинної ланки
спрямує до вузкопрофільного фахівця якщо
ви поцікавитеся у себе на місцях то ваші
сімейні лікарі
педіатри а також інші медичні працівники
пройшли спеціально спеціальне навчання
про це можна дізнатися міністерство
соціальної політики створює проект
реалізує проект створення центрів
жидкість стійкості в Україні і це саме
буде цей проект стосуватися
психосоціальна підтримка жителів громад
фахівці першої лінії контакту Тобто
безпосередньо це практичні психологи і
соціальні педагоги закладів професійної
освіти включно і волонтери Міністерство
у справах компанії упроваджуємо
впроваджуватиме свій проєкт так який не
метою буде створення
цифрового мобільного застосунку для
підтримки наших ветеранів і їхніх сімей
Коли той час коли він будуть повертатися
до мирного життя Міністерство оборони
реалізує свій проект Міністерство
внутрішніх справ теж створили алгоритм
надання психологічної допомоги та
супроводу саме в кризових станах і
екстрених ситуаціях і ось безпосередньо
що стосується нас Міністерство освіти і
науки презентувала проект психосоціальна
підтримка та психологічна допомога на
всіх рівнях освіти мета цього проекту
впровадження навичок психологічної
стійкості на всіх рівнях освіти Звичайно
це буде стосуватися і професійної освіти
а також я наголошую і на цьому це
трансформація психологі обласної служби
в системі освіти
Міністерство молоді та спорту
втілюватиме проект молодіжні центри та
активні парки це як частина екосистеми
психічного здоров'я Звичайно що ми теж Я
думаю будемо під'єднуватися до цих
проектів і наразі мета
всіх цих проектів створене ланцюжка
системи психосоціальних послуг тобто
особі у тому числі будь-які тому числі
особі з інвалідністю перш за все повинен
надаватися
всеосяжний психологічний і соціальний
супровід
тепер безпосередньо перейдемо до
психологічного супроводу осіб з
інвалідністю системи
профосвіти які у нас наразі стоять
завдання це перш за все ми повинні брати
активну участь у реалізації національної
програми відновлення ментального
здоров'я але я думаю що Шановні колеги
Що ми долучилися до цієї програми вже
так як ми
взагалі уже Працюємо з внутрішньо
переміщеними особами це теж є особи з
особливими потребами серед них є теж
особи з інвалідністю і наші соціальні
педагоги практичні психологи а також
педагогічні працівники мають основи
знань психологічного супроводу таких
осіб наразі стоїть розвиток інклюзивної
культури закладів професійної освіти наш
заклад теж
співпрацює з такими закладами
професійної освіти те що ляже на наші з
вами печі це просвітницька робота
психологічної служби з батьками та
зацікавленими особами з громадськими
організаціями от найперше це подолання
стегнації осіб з інвалідністю особливо з
ментальними видами порушень наше
суспільство ще скажемо стигматизує
інколи
демонізує осіб з ментальним видами
порушень і він їх то боїться то жаліє
суспільство і не розуміє як правильно
поводитися з такими особами тому наша
просвітницька робота повинна зайняти
чичильне місце
у цьому процесі звичайно викликом є і
підвищення психологічної культури
педагогічних працівників закладів
професійної освіти тобто психологічні
знання чітке розуміння власних
компетенції можливостей чим ми можемо
допомогти чим не можемо
повинно бути стояти на часі не тільки
для практичних
психологів соціальних педагогів А
взагалі для всієї системи для всіх
учасників освітнього процесу
звичайно потребує підвищення мотивації
діяльності усіх учасників освітнього
процесу особи з інвалідністю особливо
вони потребують допомоги у пошуку
власної психологічних і соціальних
ресурсів
безпосередньо потребує
скажемо такої
методичної підтримки супровід навчальної
діяльності таких осіб Окрім цього
вивчення і розвиток індивідуальних
психологічних
особливостей здобувачів освіти в тому
числі осіб з інвалідністю це вже буде
безпосередньо робота практичного
психолога і розвиток м'яких навичок
здобувачів тобто особливо навичок
взаємодії людини соціумом розвиток
соціальних компетенцій комунікативних і
так далі це дуже важливо для цієї
категорії осіб методичне забезпечення
роботи психологічної соціальної служби
закладів професійної освіти це завдання
буде стояти перед
центрами і кабінетами про тих освіти
також перед нашим інститутом перед
науковцями Ну і звичайно Всі ми повинні
співпрацювати з громадами та
роботодавцями у сфері реалізації програм
різних видів реабілітації осіб з
інвалідністю
[музика]
безпосередньо центр психологічного
супроводу керівником якого є нашого
інституту
запланував певні заходи для реалізації
підтримки осіб з інвалідністю якщо ми
наше головне завдання надати якомога
повну підтримку для здобувачів освіти Ми
повинні
навчити цьому практичних психологів
соціальних педагогів і взагалі всіх
педагогічних працівників Отже в червні
23-го року ми плануємо провести курс
занять для психологів і соціальних
педагогів закладів профосвіти
психологічної і соціальний супровід ось
освіти осіб з інвалідністю внаслідок
війни метою цього курсу буде володіння
теоретичними знаннями і практичними
навичками цього психологічного супроводу
Тобто ми плануємо надати конкретні
короткострокові психологічні
алгоритми допомоги
У рамках курсу запланована окремі
практичні заняття з фахівцем з
арт-терапії мартиновою Іриною євгенівною
засновницею керівником
нейро-академії в Ізраїлі це фахівець
який дуже гарно володіє
арт-терапевтичними методиками і я думаю
що це буде надзвичайно корисно
надзвичайно цікаво для наших
педагогічних працівників на цей курс
запрошується слухачі які мають базову
психологічну освіту Я наголошую саме
слухачі з базовою психологічною освітою
тому що курс розрахований саме на
спеціаліста який має право застосувати
фахові психологічні методики матеріал
буде викладений саме так як він
викладається для спеціалістів тобто не
адаптований для педагогічних працівників
які мають основи психологічних знань
на вересень 2023 року ми запланували
проведення курсу занять для педагогічних
працівників закладів професійної освіти
психологічної основи супроводу навчання
осіб з інвалідністю внаслідок війни Цей
курс розрахований на педагогів які не
мають базової психологічної освіти Тобто
ми та курсу оволодіння слухачем основами
знань і практичних умінь успішної
освітньої діяльності зі здобувачами
освіти з особливими потребами внаслідок
війни Тобто будуть подані конкретні
алгоритми поведінки і допомоги у роботі
з такими особами тобто курс буде
розрахований на фахівця педагога без
базової психологічної освіти який буде
працювати з дітьми дорослими здобувачами
професійної освіти
тобто реально
наш інститут професійної освіти
запланував цілий ряд заходів потужних
які допоможуть у підтримці
психологічному супроводі у соціальному
супроводі освіти осіб з інвалідністю
внаслідок війни і не тільки цих осіб А
взагалі всіх здобувачів освіти а
особливо тих осіб з особливими потребами
та членів їх сімей
Шановні колеги
будь ласка Слідкуйте за анонсами на
сайті
нашого інституту Там будуть подані
конкретно
дати навчання і якщо вам потрібно буде
звернутися за порадою чи уточнити якусь
інформацію будь ласка я надаю свій
e-mail Дякую за увагу
Дякую шановна Оксана Вікторівна за вашу
доповідь Я думаю обговорення ми згідно
нашому регламенту всіх трьох доповідей
проведемо в кінці презентації А зараз Я
запрошую до слова шановну Ірину
євгенівну мартинову засновницю керівника
Я вже було зазначено
нейракадемії Ізраїль вона презентує нам
доповідь Особливості застосування
нейромалювання з метою керування
психологічним станом будь ласка шановне
Ірина Євгенівна Оксана Вікторівна
попрошу вас прибрати свою презентацію
Вітаю вас колеги мене чути все добре бо
я не дуже знайома з цією кімнатою
Так ми вас чуємо чудово зараз я також
Поділюсь з вами своєю презентацією і ми
розпочнемо
так хвилинку це займе в мене декілька
секунд
хвилиночку зараз
Я не знаю чи ви вже бачите Щось я не
дуже знайома з цією кімнатою тобто чи
бачите ви зараз презентацію Поки що ні
ми бачимо чудово бачимо вас але
презентація поки що не підвантажується
А якщо ось так
о
Вона може просто повільно підвантажити
зараз видно вже ми бачимо увесь ваш
екран тепер якби ви підняли презентацію
свою було б чудово я її вже підняла але
не знаю чи ви її бачите Вибачаюсь за
такі А ось так
почалося завантаження
давайте Зачекаємо ми
науковці більш швидкі аніж інтернет
як зараз очевидно вже презентацію
поки що у мене поки що білий екран
хвилинку Давайте давайте я спробую ще
раз давайте я спробую ще раз
не знаю чому так інтернет сьогодні дуже
повільний колеги
Зараз я спробую Ще раз бо без
презентації це буде не так яскраво як це
може бути так
він мене запитує весь екран Я кажу весь
екран поділитись так і зараз піднімаю
піднімаю свою презентацію
так Ну що видно вже
поки що чекаємо Да Вже бачимо вже бачимо
чудово чудово тоді я можу розпочати Я не
бачу себе не бачу вас але саме головне
що ви бачите презентацію ми бачимо і вас
і презентацію Да будь ласка
Я хочу сьогодні
15 хвилин що в мене є спробувати
розповісти вам про те що таке
нейромалювання і про те як воно може
допомогти саме в темі
керування своїм психологічним станом
декілька слів про себе Я педагог я слів
вчителів Народилася я в місті герої
Херсоні майже все життя половини життя
прожила в Києві і другу половину життя в
Ізраїлі і я дійсно засновниця першої
української школи нейромалювання з таким
з такою чудовою назвою Нейро мрія Ну і
для того щоб це було так трошечки швидше
Ви почитайте що я там написала про себе
а я розпочну про нейромалювання це не
знаючи знайомі ви з цим Чи чули ви про
це але нермалювання це така дуже класна
і цікава і дуже ефективна технологія
керування своїм життям через малюнок
неремалювання - це можливість
зображувати на аркуші паперу не
усвідомлюваність страхи переконання
знімати напругу
опрацьовувати такі стани як Гнів тривога
і навіть не тільки опрацьовувати а
перетворювати трансформувати їх в
позитивні емоції та навіть в ресурсний
стан в мене великий досвід роботи з
нейромалюванням вже 6 років і я точно
знаю мене дуже багато учнів по всьому
світі Я працюю онлайн До речі
нейромалювання допомогло мені змінити
своє життя і з вчительки математики я
перекваліфікувалась на вчительку
нейромалювання і я точно знаю що
наймалювання допомагає також розвивати
нестандартний підхід до вирішення
багатьох задач в багатьох проблем у
різних сферах життя Що цікаво що
нейромалювання воно доступне тому не
потрібно вміти малювати взагалі Взагалі
я людина яка раніше не вміла малювати
але якщо ви бачите тут в мене за за
спиною це така творча студія Я почала
малювати Чому Тому що неремалювання
допомагає навіть змінювати нейронні
зв'язки ну про це якось окремим разом
для нермалювання потрібно деякий час
30 хвилин 60 хвилин в залежності від
того З чим працюємо І що робимо чистий
аркуш олівець або маркери або фломастери
і просто знаєте так надати цьому
можливість тому що зміни дійсно
відбуваються у 30% людей вже під час
першого малюнку це вже перевірено
досвідом
чим відрізняється неремалювання від
деяких психологічних трансформуючих
практик що не потрібно таке самокопання
не потрібно дуже глибоке занурення
спочатку І це допомагає І тому це
допомагає навіть з перших малюнків вже
змінювати свій емоційний стан і от для
того щоб якось продемонструвати вам як
виглядають ці малюнки от я хочу
поділитись в наступному слайді одним зі
своїх малюнків це я малювала на першому
На першому фото це Ось таким чином я
виштовхувала себе тривожність напругу і
трансформували це в щось інше Звичайно є
певні закони певні алгоритми як потрібно
з цим працювати але саме цьому я і
навчаю і ви бачите як з якоїсь там
кривульки каляки-маляки такої це
перетворюється на якусь таку дуже
гармонійну роботу звичайно потім
Працюємо з кольором колір це також
енергія за допомогою кольору можна ще
додатково гармонізувати стан
і тому це
дуже ефективно як можна використовувати
нейромалювання нормалювання можна
використовувати
особистих для себе для того щоб
змінювати свій стан можна для того щоб
допомагати людям тобто як додаткова
практика додатковий інструмент для
роботи з людьми це наступний рівень для
допомагаючих практиків Скажімо так і
рівень Коли можна навчати нейромалюванню
інших людей те що роблю я саме це я
роблю ну і за допомогою енергомелювання
звичайно я створюю свої трансформаційні
програми тренінги майстер-класи
використовуючи в тому числі і
нейромалювання окрім інших практик Ну і
є в мене дуже багато звичайно кейсів із
мешканцями Ізраїлю і вже з
українцями бо я розпочала свою роботу
рідною
умови після 24 лютого минулого року і
з'явилась дуже багато кейсів в нас є
дуже велика спільнота у Фейсбуці де ми
ділимось всім цим підтримуємо один
одного
хочу поділитись з вами дуже коротенько
одним кейсом з практиками минулого року
до мене особисто терапію прийшла Жінка
40 років психологиня і тема з якою вона
зайшла була Мені не подобається життя
навіть Мене лякає життя я не знаю що
робити вона зараз не в Україні а в одній
з країн Європи і спочатку от ви бачите
на я написала що перші теми для
пропрацювання були дуже такі загальні
навчання здоров’я вона не занурювалась
глибоко в якісь такі плани на майбутнє
але поступово щось трансформувалось і
навіть якість малюнків стала зовсім
іншою жінка не художниця вона не вміє
малювати просто
так воно змінювалось і наприкінці нашої
з неї роботи і тема перетворилась на
іншу тему трансформувались Тобто вона
успішна і самодостатня психологиня і
саме Так вона зараз і працює Вона працює
з діточками допомагають діточкам в
Україні
Ну і
що ми зробили вже минулого травня вже
рівно рік тому
я відчула як це сказати правильно
відчула потребу відчула такий поклик
серця зробити щось для безліч своїх
знайомих по всьому по всьому світу і ми
зробили такий проект нейромарафон
вдячності 28 днів ми малювали у
відкритому доступі всі ці практики і
досі є на моєму каналі в Ютубі відкриті
безкоштовні Це була як така психологічна
допомога вдячність за
дуже багато
дуже багато речей в нашому житті це
допомагало стабілізуватись і досі люди
малюють по цих відкритих відео але те що
пам'ятаєте Я сказала вам що
нейромалювання допомагає змінити навіть
нейронні зв'язки тобто в мене якось
мозок я вам чесно скажу працювати якось
по-іншому більш креативно більше в таких
творчих напрямках І сталося так що я
ну не відкрила
я зробила заснувала свій власний метод
Нейро кінсує якщо ви не чули ще слова
кінсугі це таке традиційне японське
мистецтво ремонту керамічного посуду але
це не тільки Мистецтво це метафора це
метафора нашого з вами життя це
кожен з нас на протязі свого життя
проходив і проходить зараз звичайно ж
дуже важкі складні ситуації і замість
того щоб маскувати свої тріщинки
склеювати себе і нікому не розповідати
не пропрацьовувати це можна за допомогою
методу кінцю і методу нейрохінтогі тобто
нейромалювання такого дуже
особливого Можна ці проблеми вирішити
тобто підкреслити те що у кожного з нас
не ідеальне життя у кожного з нас є
якісь свої тріщинки але допомогти собі
відновитись реставруватись точно так як
майстер-кінцю і реставрує свій виріб і
піти далі і сяяти новим світлом і ця
програма це мій авторський метод який
народився ще у 2019 році я поєднала в
ньому дійсно дуже глибоку філософію
кінцюгів з 15 сторіччя деякі
арт-терапевтичні практики не ремалювання
звичайно деякі методи енеопії деякі
техніки Ну і дуже багато своїх таких
відкриттів Скажімо так що в мене вже є
за 6 років метод виявився дуже дієвим
дуже дієвим тому що це дійсно така і
швидка допомога у кризових ситуаціях і
пошук нових резервів відновлення і я
бачу в цьому методі
потенціал дуже-дуже великий тобто для
педагогічних для реабілітаційних практик
Я працюю тут в Ізраїлі з
своїми клієнтами з групами ви всі знаєте
що в нас в Ізраїлі перманентно завжди
неспокійна ситуація стільки років
Скільки є скільки я тут живу стільки цей
відбувається і це не закінчиться тому
такий метод дуже актуальний і Окрім
цього звичайно метод нейрохінсугі - це
дуже ресурсна допомога для фахівців що
працюють з людьми у дні війни і
післявоєнний час звичайно по-перше для
того щоб самому залишатися в ресурсі не
вигоряти Не
гойдатися на таких емоціональних
гойдалках як то кажуть і звичайно як
супроводжуючи інструмент в роботі з
емоціями і психосоматичними розладами
однієї війни за допомогою і
нейромалювання і не
дуже цікаво знаєте Таким незвичним чином
встановлюється контакт з підлітками та з
дітьми з дітьми не дуже маленькими тобто
ну такий вік 11-12 років я працюю з
такими дітьми коли я ще працювала у
школі у 2018 році я робила зі своїми
класами Це був шостий хвилинку
шостий-сьомий клас я робила з ними
практики нейромалювання Тоді в мене ще
не було нейрохінту ми працювали над
темою наприклад тривоги та напруження
перед екзаменами бо в мене був
математичний класи всі дітки хотіли дуже
високі оцінки у нас 100 бальна система
якщо Вони отримували 95 Це була вже
трагедія особливо дівчатка і цей метод
нейромалювання коли можна викинути
виштовхнути з себе на аркуш паперу всю
цю тривогу весь цей страх переляк це
дуже допомогло Їм Вони продовжували
працювати вдома
тому що я даю такі інструменти якими
можна користуватись і вдома вже поза
межами
суспільних сумісних занять Ну от це на
сьогодні в такому коротенькому виступі
Все я хочу запросити вас по цьому банку
ви можете перейти на таке відкрите відео
Знайомство з нейромалюванням приготувати
аркуш паперу маркери олівці кольорові
або фломастери і взяти собі годинку
потім помалювати там під відео є Навіть
наші контакти можна буде запитати
показати мені свою роботу Тобто це відео
відкрите воно для вас для тих хто ще
ніколи не чув про це спробуйте відчуйте
як це для вас Ну і звичайно ж ви можете
завжди приєднатися до нас до нейро-мрії
до нашого наших відкритих каналів і
Знайти мене в соцмережах ну із пані
Оксаною Ми плануємо ще зустрітися з тими
хто буде на курсі я там буду давати
деякі такі базові основи нейромалювання
на цьому У мене все дякую Дуже вам за
увагу сподіваюсь що ми з вами Ще
побачимось і почуємось
дуже дякуємо за таку цікаву аспекти
пані Іріна який ви представили особливо
з такими посиланнями Де кожен може
відкрити для себе щось нове або
удосконалити вже ту інформацію яку він
володів ще раз дуже дякую Ми продовжуємо
і наступним до слова Я запрошую шановну
Валентину вікторівну папову доктора
економічних наук професора провідного
наукового співробітника лабораторії
зарубіжних систем професійної освіти і
навчання інституту професійної освіти
Національної академії педагогічних наук
України з доповіддю з тем технологію
професійній освіті інструмент
відновлення України зарубіжний досвід
пані вороги
виведу презентацію Да будь ласка
отже
видно мою презентацію да пані Валентина
ми бачимо вашу презентацію можете
розпочинати дякую дякую за можливість
тренд в освітість янтехнологій Отже ця
технологія у професійної вам
пропонується доповідь на тему я вам
технологію професійній освіті яким
інструмент відновлення України вже у
перші місяці після варварського
вторгнення 24 лютого 22-го року поширені
у всьому світі сподівання на швидку
поразку України розбили у незламність
проти в українців Українці започаткували
активний пошук відповіді на питання
що про перспективи розвитку після
перемоги про це свідчить Указ Президента
номер 266 від 21 квітня 2022 року та
указ про створення робочої групи освіти
і наука у проекті плазми відновлення
України
причому У цьому проекті плану
відновлення України робоча група освіти
і наука
професійну освіту розглядає як одну з
ключових сфер відновлення національної
економіки
в усьому світі
набуває поширення останніх десь
буквально 2-3 десятки років такий тренд
в освіті освітньої технології як в тім
освіта в Україні 5 серпня 20-го року
постановою Кабінету Міністрів було
схвалено концепцію розвитку
природничо-математичну освіту стіл науки
де вона визнала як ключовим напрямом для
відновлення
національної економіки
з ким означає вміння учнями або
студентами органічно поєднувати знання
набуті ними у сфері науки технології
інші нині був мистецтва і математики
рівень інтеграції знань у межах ким
освіти може бути Дисциплінарний чи коли
отримують певні знання та навички По
кожному предмету стін окремо ніж
дисциплінарним коли порушуються
традиційні дисциплінарні межі для
вирішення проблем
0,дисциплінарний чи коли розробляється
спільне навчальні програми викладачами з
різних дисциплін І тракт Дисциплінарний
це коли поєднуються дисципліни за межами
дисциплінарних кордонів та створюється
нові концепції дисциплін та результатом
втім освіти стає 7 грамотність це
логічне поєднання знань з науки техніку
інженерію математики та мистецтво а
досягнення 7 грамотності є вміння учнями
або студентами застосовувати отримані
знання для розуміння побудови світу
усвідомлення того що потрібно зробити
для розвитку суспільства економіки
місцевого та світового середовища
в концепції розвитку природничого
математичної освіти стіл зазначена це
Власне кажучи стосується вже України що
з цим освіта там щось Тім освіта має
стати одним з пріоритетів розвитку сфери
освіти складовою частиною державної
політики з підвищення рівня акцентує
увагу
конкурентоспроможності національної
економіки та розвитку людського капіталу
та одним з основних факторів
інноваційної діяльності у сфері освіти
Чи відповідає запитам економіки та
потребам суспільства
з ким освіта також визначеного концепції
є цілісною системою природничою і
математичної освітніх галузей метою яких
є розвиток особистості через формування
компетентності
природничо-наукової картини світу
світоглядних позицій і життєвих
цінностей вона планується що в концепції
України саме зазначено з використанням
страв дисциплінарного підходу базується
на практичному застосуванні наукових
математичних
технічних та інженерних знань
спрямована на Розв'язання практичних
проблем для подальшого використання тих
знань і умінь у професійній діяльності
розвиток
природничо-математичної освіти має бути
забезпечений на рівнях початковому ми
бачимо дошкільна позашкільна початкова
освіта базовому це базова середньої
позашкільна освіта профільному профільна
середня позашкільна професійна та
професійна технічна освіта а також
вищому або на рівні вищої освіти в
Україні уже в розвиток цієї концепції
проводяться конференції останню
конференція була буквально два місяці
тому 24 березня
2023 року підійде і національної
академії педагогічних наук Отже що може
дати нам з ким освіта для відновлення
Економіки України і для розвитку її
конкурентоспроможності
для того щоб зробити деякі акценти
акцентувати увагу на те що не всякий не
який економічного розвитку дає
перспективи для підвищення
конкурентоспроможності національної
макросистеми вам пропонується авторська
розробка інституційного господарський
спектр формування ВВП Ми всі знаємо що
результати діяльності будь-якої країни
національною макросистеми оцінюється за
кінцевим показником валового
внутрішнього продукту за його кількістю
на душу населення за темпами росту темпу
приросту
окремо аналізується з чого складається
цей ВВП За якими видами економічної
діяльності за затратами і за доходами
але не будь-які тип формування ВВП
забезпечує однаковою можливість для
розвитку
конкурентоспроможності будь-якої країни
Ми бачимо що на цьому спектрі
позиціоновані Україна
Таїланд зверніть увагу тут чотири рази
Тайланд а також США Японія Нідерланди
Данія Південна Корея і Китаю
позиціонування е-е відбуваються
відповідно до розробленої методології
статистичного оцінювання формування ВВП
Отже крім того що ВВП розраховується за
різними методами оцінки надзвичайно
важливе значення має те в яких умовах
воно формується в умовах командної
економіки або ринкової економіки
вільного вибору які застосовуються
технології при виробництві затратну
технології застарілі або економії супер
сучасні технології і для яких переважно
споживачів виробляють цю продукцію для
зовнішніх тобто для експорту або для
внутрішніх споживачів
яка продукція кінцевого споживання чи
проміжного проміжного споживання цих си
та напівфабрикати або машини і
обладнання і в кінці кінців яка кінцева
продукція це споживча товари народного
Взимку як ми
зазначаємо або Це продукція технологічна
і сировина Отже що ми маємо в Україні
який тип конкурентоспроможності ми маємо
в Україні Україна коли на період 90-го
року коли була у складі колишнього
Радянського Союзу мала четвертий тип
економічного розвитку До речі на цьому
спектрі показано 24 типи економічного
розвитку і грубо кажучи зі збільшенням
початкового номеру
потенціал для розвитку
конкурентоспроможності національного
макросистеми збільшується ми бачимо що
найбільш розвинені країни США Японія
Нідерланди Данія вони розташовані так би
мовити у четвертому спектрі у них тип
економічного розвитку з 21 по 24 повер
України що мала Україна на період виходу
з Радянського Союзу коли вона перебувала
у складі колишнього Радянського Союзу
вона мала четвертий тип економічного
розвитку що це означає в умовах
командної економіки на затратних
технологіях для внутрішнього проміжних
споживачів виробляли з переважно
сировина і напівфабрикати пройшло більше
30 років після здобуття Україною
незалежності зараз маємо перший тип
економічного розвитку що це означає від
командної економіки адміністративна
команда ми перестрибнули до Олег
географічно-кланової економіки але так
само ми залишились у верхній частині е-е
спектру на витратних технологіях Але
тепер вже для зовнішніх споживачів
довжесті провідних споживачів
виробляються сировина і напівфабрикати
Ми всі чудово слідкуємо за новинами які
відбуваються зараз у реальному часі
бачимо з яким проблеми ми зараз
стикаються Україна з експортом своєї
свого зерна Коли гальмують цю експорт
деякі країни не можуть прийняти і таке
інше
далі буде розглянути досить таїланда
просто звернути увагу ось показано на
цьому спектрі Тайланд 1 Тайланд 2
Тайланд 3 і тайланд-4 тайланд-4 - це вже
займає позицію в тому самому спектр
сучасний Тайланд 4 займає позиції ті
самі які США Японія і Нідерланди
причому такі кардинальні дні у розвитку
Тайланду відбули всього-на-всього
впродовж 30 років десь 1983 по 2014 рік
Що зараз відбулось у Тайланді часто
сільського господарства за цей час
скоротилась з 21 пункту до 11-ти більше
ніж як на 10%. зато зросла частка
промисловості послуг з 30 до 37%
у структурі експорту у три рази
скоротилась частка аграрного експорту а
за то а син транспортного обладнання і
електроніки зросла більше ніж усім разів
з 5,6% до
46-80%. завдяки чому ти це стало
можливим це таке такі такі кардинальні
дні
у розвитку таїланда відбулись завдяки
тому що в 2012 році інститутом сприяння
освіти і науки та організації міністрів
освіти і південно-східної Азії офіційно
було запроваджено з ким освіти в туалеті
у цій освіті кардинально змінилась роль
вчителя який мав застосовувати ніж
дисциплінарній творчий підхід до
навчальної програми а також учня е-е
задачу вчителя було розвивати його
творче сприйняття та вплив на Навчальні
матеріали в ключову роль причому там
зіграла освіта Отже уряд розробив
концепцію Таїланд 1 тайла- поступово
переходу від Таїланду один до Таїланду 4
Тайланд 1 передбачав це десь приблизно
була середина 80-х років спеціалізувався
Де експорті дислови
сільськогосподарської продукції з
низькою часткою доданою вартістю
завданнями освіти було підготувати
найманих працівників Таїланд 2
спеціалізувався на виробництві товарів
легкої промисловості та первинні
переробці сільськогосподарської сировини
переважно для експорту завданням освіти
було навчити працівників підтримувати ці
технології працювати на тих технологіях
Тайланд 3 спеціалізувати на експорті
технологічної продукції переважно за
рахунок іноземних інвестицій і
технологій завдання освіти три стала
можливість навчити учнів навчатися
самостійно насамперед і врешті-решт
сучасний тайланд-4 спеціалізується на
експорті
високотехнологічної продукції яка не
залежить від іноземних інвестицій а
завданням Освіти 4 стала навчити
студентів вчитися в ключову роль у зміні
підходів зіграла саме
професійно-технічна освіта або
професійно освіта отут наведена на 16-му
слайді декілька цитат дуже поважної
джерел де зазначено що ключем до
тайської професійної освіти 4 нагадує
яка перетворила Тайланд аграрної України
без винуту конкурентос Україну став
вчитель який ініціював зміни в освіті
вчителі професійно-технічних училищ мали
коригувати свої методики навчання та
змінюватися разом зі студентами вони
також мають коригувати свою оцінку щоб
вона відповідала їм
китайські викладачі професійно оцінки
освіти мали змінити своє мислення
перейшовши від підготовки кваліфікованих
робітників до заохочення студентів до
інновації винахідництва та
підприємництва тому що Власне кажучи
можливість
перейти в тайландові Тайланду один до
Таїланду 4 - це зробили люди які є
основним інноваційним активом будь-якої
економіки що Власне кажучи цей досвід
дає нам для України
Отже дослідження закордонного досвіду
запровадження з ким освіти показала
гнучкість його інструментарію з
можливістю модифікації відповідно до
певних історичних умов і цільових
настанов До речі запровадження з ким у
світі в Таїланді воно не було просто
банальним копіюванням підходів вони
адаптували в тім освіту під своє
національну ментальність актуальним для
подальших досліджень ні успішно для
України є успішний досвід наголосу на
формування підприємницького потенціалу
який був реалізований таким освіти
Таїланду в Україні яка має перший тип
економічного розвитку відповідно до
інституційного господарського спектру
формування ВВП має бути надзвичайно
корисним досвід Тайланду адже це
дозволить Україні
переорієнтуватися з виробництва дешевої
сировини сільськогосподарського
призначення на експорт на виробництво
високотехнологічних то з високою доданою
вартістю та інтегруватись у сучасних
цифрове суспільство
запровадження державного приватного
партнерства в професійній освіті України
відкриє можливості для комплексного
вирішення освітянського господарських
робіт Натомість ми бачимо що запровадити
досвід з цим освіти можливо тільки для
того щоб змінити конкурентну модель
економічного розвитку України можна
тільки разом
синхронами діями уряду в особі Кабінету
Міністрів Міністерства Верховної Ради що
нам зараз пропонує уряд
буквально нещодавно нас
прем'єр-міністр виступав з програми які
пропонується перетворити післявоєнну
Україну на ресурсний центр Європи
і
розроблений вже план який включають десь
850 проектів і переважно ці проекти
спрямовані на переробку первинної на
первинну переробки сільськогосподарських
сировини і металопродукція Отже що нам
даного випадку пропонує уряд уряд
пропонує консервувати найгірший тип
економічного розвитку для України перший
який немає абсолютно ніяких перспектив і
можливості досягнути 21 другого третього
там четвертого типу розвитку - це є
варіант здобуття спроможності повністю
унеможливілля тому відповідно
економістом економісти мають проводити
конференцію для того щоб обгрунтовувати
що цей тип економічного розвитку
неприйнятний для України а для інституту
професійної освіти надзвичайно
великий потенціал має власне кажучи
вивчення досвіду стягну освіти для того
щоб його бути готовими запровадити на
усіх рівних особливо як було наголошено
тут актуальна змінювати методики
навчання А це власне авангарді
запроваджений з кимось освіти і зміни
підходу до навчання концепції та
навчання особливо професійно-технічні
оцінки яка має стає ключем для розбудови
після воєнної України безумовно має бути
інститут професійної освіти Дякую за
увагу
Дякуємо вам шановна Валентина Вікторівна
про актуалізацію такої проблеми Отже
Шановні колеги Сьогодні ми з вами
прослухали так би мовити дві сторони
одного процесу перше - це
психологічна складова адаптації в
зв'язку з військовими діями а також
аспекти такого педагогічної підготовки
здобувачів освіти у контексті опанування
сучасного та післявоєнного ринку праці
на що можна сподіватися на що звертати
увагу
чи є зацікавлені сторони чи коментарі
запитання до наших доповідачів з боку
слухачів будь ласка можна писати в чат
можна безпосередньо повідомляти в
особистим
вона посилання з qr-коду можна ще раз
повторити в чаті
ви будете переглядати запис на інституту
і в новинах інституту професійної освіти
Там будуть закріплені відеозаписи цих
елементів і можна ще раз переглянути і
побачити Хоча зараз я бачу в чаті від
дубльованої інформації
Я бачу що проблема психологічного
супроводу і Нейро
малювання зацікавило слухачів да
сподіваюсь що проведення така
інформаційна зустріч була корисною і
оскільки немає запитань до доповідачів
інститут професійної освіти національна
академії педагогічних наук України
особі керівництва директора Валентина
Олександрівни ранкевич доктора
педагогічних наук професора дійсно члена
Академика национальной академії
педагогічних наук України
висловлює вдячність за прийняту роботу
вдячності всім доповідачам Шановні
колеги ми відкриті до співпраці всі
контакти знаходяться в мережі Всім дякую
нам всім Перемоги до зустрічі до
побачення
Дякуємо До побачення